the ISD Institute for strategic dialogue
they're in the same kind of space as
ccdh and in their submission for the
Online safety bill they seemed quite
rattled that a video by Brendan O'Neill
was viewed many more times than one by
David Attenborough and Brendan O'Neill
was talking about politicians at clock
26 being Hypocrites for turning up in
private jets and you see people in this
space really don't like that they want
the David Attenborough video to do well
and rather than engage with why people
might be angry about hypocrisy or why
they might have skepticism and why they
might be right to be skeptical they want
to just label all his misinformation to
try to reduce engagement with it so I
don't know the internet's the ccdh case
but I have a suspicion I think a lot of
people will share or resonate with
people that what they really don't like
is Free Speech because there are certain
sorts of speech they don't agree with
and they want to just turn the volume
down on it